[Music]
now
[Music]
documentary about the uh woodstock night
didn't watch that and watch that tonight
oh it's so good hell yeah it's i always
wondered like those clips of dmx in
front of 500 that clip is like holy yeah
i would see that on twitter all the time
especially like after he passed people
would be posting that i'm like what is
this i've never seen this many people in
one place in my entire life and it was
woodstock 99. yeah i think it was 500
000 people in the crowd in the middle of
like an airfield like a military
airfield i just have to highlight that
like you know you could argue like just
because media is different and how
artists are able to reach people and
create niches and blah blah blah i think
specifically dmx in that clip
i don't know
it's crazy how dmx could perform at
woodstock where there's arguably
maybe there aren't that many rap fans
there or people who would necessarily
like understand dmx as a person and his
music yeah i feel like dmx is one of
those special people where his sound and
like his style you could literally like
everybody knows
who he is oh yeah and for him to do his
music and you have that
like one voice all the way to the back
of that airfield everyone's like i
[ __ ] know that yeah that's crazy oh
yeah and it's his voice yeah
he's performing yeah like [ __ ]
rolling
where it's just literally them hopping
around the song yeah he's like he's up
there yeah he's like [ __ ] rapping his
ass off this is my [ __ ] yeah yeah man
yeah that's an unbelievable clip yeah
woodstock 99 was just a train wreck it
gets super dark too like really dark
like a lot of like it starts with like
you know
i don't know like they had a
pay-per-view program where you could buy
it if you if you didn't want to go yeah
so they had a whole bunch of camera
dudes there
that were like basically
really focusing on women like showing
their boobs oh dude yeah so yeah like
the whole event got
super like rapey because
dudes were like women were crowd surfing
with their tops off and dudes would just
grope them and then it gets like even
more dark than that because it just
descends into chaos because so many
things went wrong it was like 100 and
some degrees out on a black tarmac
airfield yeah with 500 000 people by the
third day by sunday it was like people
were ripping the plywood off and burning
it so like during red hot chili pepper
set you look over and there's like
it looks like apocalyptic there's like
500 000 people and then in the middle
there's gigantic bonfires i thought i
remember back in the day
i thought someone cut up like a like a
highlight reel of like those topless
shots from woodstock i feel like there
that was like on like kazaa or something
like i want to say i remember like a
like elementary school friends like
older brother being like dude you got to
see this those bonfires make me think of
when i saw the one time i saw rage live
uh it was like it was that same [ __ ] it
was like the closer it got to their set
there were more bonfires on this giant
hill yeah people just like packed up
around them it's like unbelievable it's
so crazy and like this
it brought me back when i was watching
so basically on saturday kind of when
the chaos was like from the beginning
but it just gets worse and worse day by
day yeah and they play it out like as
the lineup progresses like the chaos you
can just feel it right there's like this
palpable negative energy that just gets
worse and worse as the day goes on and
so they're like
you know timing the day out by the set
and they're like so when limp biscuit
came on it was the headline set on
saturday and people are going crazy like
people are moshing like so [ __ ] hard
that's when they started ripping the
plywood off and kids were crowd surfing
on the plywood so the organizers were
like yo people are going to like die if
this doesn't calm down so they went to
fred durst and they're like can you just
calm it down and fred durst went out and
did this like giant two-minute monologue
in the middle of i forget what song it
was but it's the one with break chainsaw
is that break stuff yeah yeah in the
middle of break stuff break [ __ ]
whatever where like they're playing this
bridge basically just repeating the same
bar over and over again to build tension
yeah it's like and he's like if you feel
any negative energy right now
if anything's wrong in your life and
it's a bunch of like privileged white
here we go
yeah
this is after they told them to cool it
to try to calm people down so people
don't die
all that negative energy
let that [ __ ] out of your [ __ ] system
you got girl problems
you got boy problems
you got parent
problems problems
you got job problems
you got a problem with me
you got a problem with yourself
it's time to take all that negative
energy and put it the [ __ ] out cause
right now i'm dangerous
i'm skinny your ass wrong
give me something to break that's the
worst the worst line that these people
could be hearing
yeah so like that was the that was the
the gist you know that was like my
conclusion afterwards it just reminded
me of how [ __ ] awful limp biscuits
lyrics are yeah a skinny ass raw imagine
you're saturday night at the most
chaotic festival ever 500 000 people
there and you're at the climax and you
build that energy up like that yeah just
to say
give me something to break i mean i
think for lint biscuit too they were so
hated that it was like oh we're just
gonna double down triple down and just
send this [ __ ] to the moon yeah
this is our like rockstar moment which
honestly good on them because i would
have did the same [ __ ] yeah it was so
funny how he got by his whole career
just with all the dumbass lyrics he had
i'll skin your ass raw i'll pack a
chainsaw you're an [ __ ] oh yeah this
is the worst limb biscuit lyrics right
here coming raw with no corrections
saving all perfections for what i do
with my erections
what yeah that that's literally just
like what rhymes
i mean it doesn't
it's my ass and your perfume they make
temptation hard to refuse yeah he ra he
literally raps like a like a gnome in
world of warcraft
[Music]
i feel bad for fred because you know he
turned out to be like this sort of like
nice guy or whatever but what do you
mean he did like a reddit ama where
everyone was just [ __ ]
he was just like
yeah that's me man
not a single nice thing it was like
what is it like knowing like you're the
worst artist in the history of man he's
like
it's a title i guess
just like
beaten to applaud jesus christ so the
point that you know angry people on
reddit would say things like damn i kind
of feel bad like he just seems like a
regular guy yeah i mean i just like so
one of the
i don't know one of the the guys that
they had on
like commentating he was or like just
giving his opinions about
this era was because he was like trying
to like also
analyze
why the culture was the way it was yeah
what led up to this yeah and you know
why new metal even became a thing yeah
because this weirdest period like you
look back
you know like woodstock traditionally
was classic rock and i think like they
did it two years earlier and somewhere
else in new york and it was like this
incredible
festival with like you know amazing
culturally important music yeah two
years later it's like kid rock limp
biscuit pod like horn like creed corn
yeah this weird lineup
and so they're basically this one guy is
just making fun of it and he's like it's
crazy like the way that white people
like take something like hip-hop or
something and just remove the soul and
the the artistic the artistic partner
like limbus is the perfect example of
that so is kid rock yeah kid rock came
on stage in this gigantic white [ __ ]
like mink oh yeah i remember that [ __ ]
dude yeah cause i remember you know when
he did end together now with a method
man ever you know
i feel like kids saw that and they were
like oh method man's dope so like that
was really smart on their part to appear
like they got a co-sign from method man
yeah right to like help them legitimize
themselves
but yeah you and then you'd like go
listen to them on their other music and
you're like what the
what is this
it's like bad hip hop drum loops you
know and it's like this this [ __ ] is off
like it's like a pack of chainsaw this
one no doubt that no doubt i love too i
love
sniff on them panties now sweet oh my
god and some people might go oh well rap
music now doesn't have a lot of
it's like shut up man there are plenty
of artists out there that you just don't
go looking for it's like you can't use
the mainstream as a representative of
[ __ ] art style yeah like and
especially for this period when you had
dudes like dmx like who were like really
like writing about their life and how
they grew up and like his aggression and
all that was real because he came from
like a [ __ ] tough ass background yeah
yeah and then to be followed by this
bozo who's like
[Music]
punching drywall as a [ __ ]
uh that's what you got that's drywall
wrap yeah punching drywall give me
something to break dude i'm [ __ ]
pissed dude i'm pissed man then all
those people went back to you know
orange county and they were like dude
woodstock was crazy man i punched some
girl in the head
you